c'était lundi dans l'émission american
idol où elle est jurée la star a décidé
sur un coup de tête de se lancer dans
une interprétation de son titre teenage
dream quand soudain le pantalon à
traquer rien de bien grave c'est une
professionnelle une solution a vite été
trouvée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la raie bouclée ou de l'art et velu
laquelle pourrait vous un jour déguster
si l'envié vous en prend
j'ai moyens en vie quand même mais l'art
est devenu l'art et bouclé
montrait tout de suite une photo mais on
l'appelle ainsi à cause des épines
corner sur son dos
la raie bouclée peut mesurer jusqu'à un
mètre vingt et on est quand même sur une
très belle région va pas se mentir
qu'est ce qu'on sait sur notre croco
travail il aime la funk il n'est pas dit
matters télé il porte à gauche
ah bah on avait la remarque et il aime
le rose voilà ce qu'on sait pour le
moment sur d'autres croco il a dit quoi
il a dit quoi il doit être dit
mais pas on était nature y est les
premières fiancée que j'ai eu avec le
permis de conduire obtient goethe amené
chez moi
et donc ont passé un contrôle et tout
d'un coup en allant vers le bungalow de
mes parents elle voyait et des mecs
jouent à poil au volet et des mec à poil
en vélo et des mecs à la pétanque à poil
et on me dit m la réflexion étaient ils
sont tous à poil je dis bah oui on
aurait tous cette capacité de se
soulager et d'apaiser nos émotions à la
il ya un petit exercice un peu
au lala tout l'esprit mal placé pas que
des enfants qui nous regardent cadors
cette émission
pas si sûr
griller des saucisses dans la nature je
crois que c'est vraiment une définition
du bonheur à la finlande est des
plaisirs simples
à l'image de ce pays sans chichis je
vais te présenter mes parents et mon
père est sorti et là tu as l'air
évidemment il va dit bonjour
naturellement puisque c'est nous ça nous
et nous choquer pas ma mère allait lui
arriver derrière bonjour mademoiselle
enchanté et donc on était tout d'un coup
dans une déprime totale de la part de la
jeune fille qui était là et qu'ils
n'étaient pas au courant qu'elle allait
se retrouver évidemment sur cinq minutes
après à poil mon mari ne fait le pire
compliment qu'on peut faire une femme et
était persuadé que c'était une phrase
très romantique autant je vous assure
qu'ils peuvent aider à l'époque contre
isabelle imedi chérie je te serai
toujours fidèles en reste que moi les
jolies femmes j'ai jamais osé les
aborder non
qu'est ce qu'il fout là votre
chroniqueur
je ne découvre via naulleau signe à
forest lawn est pas notre candidat de
parler d'eric zemmour est bon comme moi
j'aime bien avec les six ans journal du
hard c'est quelqu'un qui a le coeur sur
la main j'ai fait des clubs libertins
mecs très sympas ils calculent mouvance
il aime la france qu'est ce qui est fait
au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit
rosso et dress code noir
les musiciens réinterprète à la sauce
métal des textes qui n'ont rien de
provocateur
[Musique]
et juste avant de terminer parce que
geoffroy le jeune et et matthieu bock
fonds vont oublier de le faire et ça va
alors faire de la peine c'est le ramadan
donc ramadan moubarak
ils vont complètement vierge le
souhaitez et moi je vous dis ben comme
dirait ali et eric zemmour à la semaine
prochaine
[Rires]